we can talk to the party Shadow foreign
secretary David Lammy thank you very
much for being on the program this
morning Mr Lammy and so we just heard
from Dominic Robb there saying that
there's been real progress on a brexit
deal that he's hopeful it will come in a
matter of days rather than weeks
um if that does get over the line will
you back it
look yes I think that labor is
determined to act in the national
interests of our country and of Northern
Ireland it's very likely that if a deal
does emerge it will be an improvement on
the Northern Ireland protocol deal that
was struck by Boris Johnson just a few
years ago and deal with the issues of
goods and services
particularly trafficking from the United
Kingdom into Northern Ireland and then
into the Republic of Ireland and for
that reason we have indicated that we
expect to support this deal when it
emerges I suspect in the next few days
we've got a bit of detail on what we
expect it to be from Dominic Robb as the
kind of red light green light system
depending on whether goods are going to
stay in Northern Ireland or go to the EU
um a bit of credit for getting the EU to
move
well look I think that it's important
that he's rolled his sleeves up and got
on with negotiation that's what the
labor party was saying for months and
months and months and we finally got
there but it is important that he's
included the unionists within that
dialogue he should have probably have
done that months and months ago so that
they felt included and of course there
are concerns about the ERG and his own
back benches but notwithstanding that if
he does get a deal then credit to him
because this is hugely important for the
national interests of our country and
for people of Northern Ireland we want
uh Power sharing to get back we want
storm and to get back and certainly
businesses and the community in Northern
Ireland do not want unnecessary friction
at the border
you mentioned the dep there and the
importance of keeping them on site and
they're pretty clear on this aren't they
they're a unionist party they don't want
Northern Ireland to be treated any
differently to other parts of the United
Kingdom whether that's Cardiff or
Newcastle or London they want Northern
Ireland to be treated in the same way
have they got a point
look Northern Ireland is part of the
United Kingdom so of course they don't
want it treated differently the dup set
out seven tests no doubt they will want
to scrutinize any deal that comes
forward over the coming days and they
will make their judgment on the basis of
those seven tests that set they set out
but it's hugely important that any deal
catches the spirit of the Good Friday
agreement over 30 years just under 4 000
people lost their lives in those
Troubles of course this is a serious
moment and it requires careful heads and
reflection
you know where to put the border for the
reasons that you've mentioned is
arguably you know the biggest unsolvable
problem with brexit unless of course the
whole of the UK rejoins a single Market
I mean you obviously campaigned for
remain if labor get into power do you
think that should be on the table
look it was always the case if we go
back a few years that people were
raising issues of a border that could
emerge between the Republic of Ireland
and Northern Ireland that was Remedy by
not having a border effectively uh in
the South but I visited Derry
Londonderry I was at foil Port looking
at some of the issues that arise for
business there they were doing
everything they can to ease any friction
and minimize any sorts of Customs checks
but there was always more to build on
that's why we look forward to seeing the
detail of this deal as it's emerged
that's why it's important that all sides
are able to consider that carefully
there should be no rush I think on any
vote in Parliament people are entitled
to look at the small print in detail but
I hope now that all of us can come
together to vote through any deal and
get back to stormant underpinned by The
Good Friday agreement and move on from
this episode that has now gone on for
many years indeed
it was nicely sidestepped I know of
course that you were one of the
politicians who had concerns about where
to put a border before The brexit Vape
perhaps one of the reasons why you
campaigned for remain but the question
is looking forward do you think it
should be on the table that the UK
rejoined a single Market if labor was in
power
look I think that most of your viewers
will not want to go back to the ranker
and the divisions that dominated this
country after that referendum vote the
truth is that when you speak to the
European Union when you visit
capitals people want a warm and friendly
relationship between the United Kingdom
and Europe I'm afraid because of the
issues that have risen over the Northern
Ireland protocol we've not been able to
make progress with our European partners
and we've got a government where we had
a former prime minister Liz trust
describe president macron as a foe or an
enemy we need to get back to structured
dialogue with the European Union so we
can discuss the challenges ahead of us I
think we need to make progress on
Horizon on mobility issues for our young
people and students and we can deal with
issues of qualifications and touring our
artists those sorts of issues and of
course we've got the review of the trade
agreement that we struck with them in
2025 so there's much to do but going
back into the European Union it's
absolutely clear that we roll out the
single Market we rule out the Customs
Union and frankly we're going to have a
lot to do if we form a government at the
end of 2024. okay understood
um now I spoke to Bernie Sanders this
week we'll hear the interview a little
bit later in the program he said that he
would like to see leaders like Joe Biden
and kirst armor be a bit more radical
because he doesn't accept that in
politics you'll win from the center and
he also said that Labor's NHS plan to
use some spare capacity in the private
sector makes them a bit nervous do you
think he's got a point on any of that
look I think that the missions that were
set out this week are just that
ambitious plan uh wanting to have growth
the highest growth in the G7 comparably
is ambitious what it means is jobs it
means that we can get past the cost of
living crisis that people are
experiencing a clean energy power by
2030 gets us into the Super League where
we need to be it benefits all businesses
across our country and of course people
when you knock on their doors they're
raising issues around safer streets
they're raising issues around our young
people and the opportunities that are
available to them and of course the
Health Service all of these things need
attending to it lives up to our
inheritance the inheritance of Clement
Atlee after the second world war Howard
Wilson that was dealing with the white
heat of technology and reforming all
sorts of issues across our country it's
an ambitious plan we'll set out further
details in the area of Health crime
particularly in education over the
coming months but at the next general
election there will be a clear dividing
line hope Vision ambition from the labor
party and people will look at what the
Tories have achieved over the last 13
years and I'm sorry but it's hard to
point to anything
okay two very quick questions uh to
squeeze in um firstly you're calling for
the Wagner group the Russia militia Army
to be classified as a terrorist
organization explain why
this is a terrible terrible militia
causing havoc in Ukraine and a loss of
life closely attached to Vladimir Putin
they're also acting in places like Syria
and the Horn of Africa of course we
shouldn't just sanction them we should
prescribe them as a terrorist
organization right across the house
people have been raising issues and
that's why I'm calling along with a vet
Cooper for the wagler group to be
prescribed today
okay and very very quickly because I
know you need to go Dominic Robb
announcing today transgender women
who've committed violent or sexual
offenses can't be housed in mainstream
women's prisons is that the right policy
look I think that this is a sensitive
issue but clearly someone born uh a male
a man who uh is a predator or who is
violent towards women has to be assessed
appropriately and should not be in a
woman's prison I've spent many years
with an interest in Justice and Justice
issues in the House of Commons women's
prisons are very very uh difficult
places with lots of vulnerable prisoners
but equally there are trans women who
are vulnerable so it's important that
you make the right evidence base risk
assessment as to the appropriate place
for that prisoner to be okay thank you
very much indeed for being on the show
David let me there